fait partie du clan des bobos jean
pierre pernaut il invité au quotidien
donc ça va bien après c'est brice c'est
vrai que quotidien l'invité lire à leurs
élèves noirs des jaunes et non des
années là maintenant il est bien il est
hype il est comme il faut je vais vous
dire vous savez quand vous faites partie
d'un groupe et que vous avez un gros
contrat vous prenez les invités vous
vous dites prendrez vous fermez votre
gueule
évidemment quotidien opaque quotidien il
faisait sur canal+ mine de rien et je
vous le dis je dis la vérité il avait
une totale liberté sur tf1 c'est pas la
même chose il ya déjà des années
franchement jamais invité d'ailleurs
consulter son coffre exactement il
ajouté hier d'ailleurs j'en extrais de
jean pierre pernaut chez quotidien et
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein d'internautes
qui ont dit tiens c'est bizarre
quotidien c'était le pour accepter le
nouveau petit journal de canal+
quand il n'appartenait pas aux groupes
tf1 et ses revenus c'est très souvent à
se moquer de jean pierre pernaut
regardez d'ailleurs on a les images il a
vu passer
écoutez bien s'ils président de la
république il est toujours là tel en
europe voici jean pierre pernaut
[Applaudissements]
diffusez 96000 reportage dans le jt de
13h vous présenter le cinquième jt le
plus puissant de la planète
c'est le journal le plus jeune de france
oui donc le média le plus jeune de
france c'est pernaut oui on m'a dit ça
c'est la classe d'être dans un
houellebecq et les parisiens pêche
artisanale et saucisses peut être j'en
sais rien moi dont il ya quelques médias
qui avaient malheureusement ça voilà
alors donc ça c'était hier et je vais
vous dire ça ce qu'on va voir
c'était avant regardez dans le petit
journal regard d'un il y avait de
l'émotion hier émotion larmes parfois
oui de l'émotion comme l'an dernier pour
les plus petits et leurs parents bat
toujours autant d'émotion le loubard de
la semaine c'est lui un siècle de vente
par correspondance on revoit les
fameuses bien attention surprise
1 2 3 soleil auteur jean-pierre pernaut
jean pierre pernaut a repris sa place au
13 heures de tf1 la rédaction a repris
les bonnes vieilles habitudes des
triplés de nancy qui passent le bac
ensemble or des triplés qui passent le
bac alors ça c'est cocasse voilà alors
donc ça c'était avant
et on l'avait dit hein c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué pour eux d'avoir la même
liberté d'expression comme quand il
était sur canal+ tf1 c'est une grosse
machine vous connaissez maintenant même
temps à 130000 euros le bout c'est
normal content parce que le processeur
130000 euros
le quotidien au quotidien vous donner
tous les prix trente mille euros
absolument alors oui donc non mais c'est
vrai on fait quelques concessions tête
en fait ce qu'on veut non la vérité non
halal à me l'agapa mais bon quand on
rentre à tf1 à décharge on sait très
bien où on va donc mais des règles on
doit être du côté de la chaîne et moi
j'ai avalé des couleuvres je pense que
tout le monde doit en aval et si on veut
pas les avaler faut pas aller sur tf1
mais la tendance irait mais mais à part
vous sur aucune chaîne on fait ce qu'on
veut même tourné petit que jeudi un
groupe nrj 12 et sur equidia j'ai vu
qu'ils sont ils ont rénové des poneys
sur toutes les scènes du monde quand on
dit du mal de son petit camarade on est
convoqué par la direction c'est normal
il n'y a que vous qui n'avez rien à
[ __ ] de rien
[Rires]
mais je vous jure qu'il n'y a pas que
moi parce que dans le groupe
j'vous jure que c'est vrai c'est pas
pour défendre mon groupe à pour défendre
le groupe canal chacun fait ce qui lui
plaît moitié rare dit son nom il nous
est arrivé ici de le fracasser
d'instruction thierry il m'appelle
derrière elle dit c'est le principe je
comprends et la direction si c'est comme
ça thierry il a fait des trucs même sur
nous il est fort sur l ex quoi demain où
william leymergie à midi ni au fait tous
pas mon poste ne regardez pas au sort
c'est vraiment de la merde mais les
poubelles
[Rires]
comme moi ce qui me gêne avec quotidien
il donne des leçons aux autres
on voulait donner des leçons aux autres
vous même il faut être propre
eux ils balancent sur tous les autres il
faudra mieux de se regarder que c'est
pas bien ce qu'ils font si vous invitez
pernaut lui poser des questions
agressives les vraies questions à la con
si c'est pour vous allez nous faire mais
c'est vrai ça m'énerve ça m'énerve quand
vous donnez des leçons il faut être
honnête je ne verrai pas moi j'aime bien
plus le petit yann barthès franchement
louly le petit somme énorme et le petit
japonais mais on est sûr faut bien
qu'ils étaient km 68 merci rien